ahora veamos qué pasaría si tenemos este
ácido carboxílicos y lo hacemos
reaccionar con este alcohol en una
solución que tiene como catalizador al
ácido sulfúrico bueno para empezar vamos
a ver cómo se llaman estas dos cosas
aquí este ácido carboxílicos tiene 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 carbonos entonces es un
y en lugar de ponerla o ponemos la
terminación de que es un ácido
carboxílicos o sea le ponemos
y decimos que es un ácido ácido por otro
lado este es un alcohol que tiene 12
carbonos entonces es un
tal y como es un alcohol como tiene este
grupo o h entonces usa la terminación o
el etanol y nos encontramos a estas dos
moléculas en la presencia de ácido
sulfúrico este de aquí es
ácido
sulfúrico
y este ácido es uno de los ácidos más
fuertes y bueno vamos a poner por aquí
su estructura porque eso nos puede decir
por qué es que este ácido es tan fuerte
el ácido sulfúrico siempre tenemos que
empezar con el azufre azufre que tiene 6
electrones de valencia y cuando lo
encontramos en el ácido sulfúrico tiene
dos enlaces dobles con oxígeno y un
enlace de doble otro enlace doble y los
otros dos electrones de valencia los use
para enlazarse también con oxígeno pero
estos oxígenos forman parte de un grupo
o h
h y listo ahí está el azufre con 1 2 3 4
5 6 electrones de valencia y bueno se
puede ver en esta estructura que es un
ácido super fuerte o sea para empezar
tiene dos grupos funcionales o h y
además está súper estabilizado por
resonancia no creeis y este oxígeno se
queda con el electrón de este hidrógeno
se lo puede muy fácilmente dar al azufre
y que el azufre suelte uno de estos
electrones ok tiene mucha resonancia y
es muy electro negativo pero bueno si
quieres saber más acerca del ácido
sulfúrico seguro puedes encontrar un
vídeo en cama cavem y mientras tanto
regresemos a esto siempre que tienes una
reacción que está haciendo catalizada
por algún ácido lo que esto te está
diciendo es que la solución va a ser
súper ácida es que la solución va a ser
más ácida que tal vez tenemos aquí ácido
tánico en una solución de etanol con
ácido sulfúrico como catalizador y
entonces esta solución se vuelve mucho
más ácida de hecho muchos protones van a
dar a moléculas de etanol pero bueno
vamos a dibujar estos hidrógenos del
ácido sulfúrico de esta forma y tenemos
una molécula de etanol por aquí o sea
tenemos el oxígeno un hidrógeno con sus
dos pares de electrones y bueno el ácido
sulfúrico es súper bueno quedándose con
los electrones y expulsando los protones
de estos dos hidrógenos y entonces al
mismo tiempo que este oxígeno se queda
con este electrón este otro oxígeno del
etanol le da uno de sus electrones al
protón del núcleo del hidrógeno y
entonces lo que nos queda es un montón
de estas moléculas de etanol con un
protón más o sea tenemos por aquí lo
rote un poco el oxígeno con sus dos
pares de electrones
y aquí tenía un hidrógeno pero le regaló
uno de sus electrones a este hidrógeno
por aquí entonces ahora hay un enlace
entre estos dos y el oxígeno tiene una
carga positiva por otro lado el ácido
sulfúrico se deshizo de un protón y
entonces tenemos aquí el azufre doble
enlace con el oxígeno doble enlace con
el oxígeno 1 o h y luego un oxígeno con
una carga negativa donde este electrón
extra puede saltar al azufre haciendo un
doble enlace con este oxígeno y bueno de
hecho esta molécula se encuentra en
resonancia entonces todos estos
electrones están soltando por todos
lados de una forma muy estable y bueno
hicimos todo esto para que vieras un
poco mejor al ácido sulfúrico viera su
estructura y cómo funciona y por qué es
tan ácido
lo que hay que recordar es que si
tenemos como catalizador a un ácido
entonces lo que va a suceder en nuestra
solución es que vamos a tener un montón
de protones flotando por ahí y eso va a
hacer que la protón acción o sea la
adición de un protón a una molécula
suceda muchísimo y muy rápido porque hay
entonces todas estas moléculas están
sujetas a ser protón hadas en cualquier
instante si en lugar de estar en una
solución de etanol estuviéramos en una
solución de agua entonces nos
encontraríamos con muchísimos iones
hidronew entonces como tenemos a un
catalizador de ácido sulfúrico en
cualquier momento de la reacción no
sería nada loco que yo de repente
agregar a un protón por ahí o que nos
encontremos con muchísimos de estos
iones del etanol sería algo
completamente razonable así es que ahora
sí vamos con la reacción tenemos nuestro
ácido están hoy ccoo por aquí
1 2 3 4 5 6 7
con el doble enlace con el oxígeno y el
grupo h y este oxígeno tiene sus dos
pares de electrones libres y bueno como
nos encontramos en una solución con
ácido sulfúrico como catalizador
entonces tenemos muchos protones
flotando por allí tenemos un protón por
aquí o sea el núcleo de un hidrógeno que
pudo haber venido del ácido sulfúrico o
de uno de estos iones del etanol ok pero
el chiste es que tenemos aquí en nuestro
protón tal vez este protón cuando nos lo
encontramos era parte de algunas de
estas dos moléculas y tenía su electrón
pero el electrón se queda en estas
moléculas y nos quedamos únicamente con
este protón entonces tenemos nuestro
ácido tánico con un protón y lo que
sucede naturalmente es que el oxígeno le
regale un electrón a este protón y
entonces pues tenemos aquí nuestro ácido
tánico
con el grupo h y el oxígeno con doble
enlace y este oxígeno tenía sus dos
pares de electrones pero le acaba de
regalar un electrón a este protón y por
lo tanto este protón ya no tiene carga
positiva pero ahora este oxígeno como
regalo uno de sus electrones ahora tiene
una carga positiva y necesitamos más
espacio a ver estamos en una solución de
etanol entonces seguro nos encontramos
un etanol por ahí con este oxígeno con
sus dos pares de electrones y bueno como
este oxígeno tiene una carga negativa y
el oxígeno es muy electro negativo
entonces seguramente está abrazando
bastante estos dos electrones del
carbono haciendo que este carbono tenga
bastante carga parcial positiva y que
esto sea un grupo saliente entonces esta
molécula de etanol que es electro fila
puede atacar a este carbono que tiene
una carga parcial positiva dándole
uno de sus electrones y entonces uno de
estos dos electrones va a dar al oxígeno
y entonces una vez más el oxígeno tiene
una carga neutra nada más que ahora
tiene un enlace simple y hay un enlace
entre este carbono y este oxígeno ya
ahora vamos a ver como sobre nuestras
moléculas después de esto tenemos 2 3 4
5 6 7 carbonos este es el carbono del
grupo car box y lo pero ahora ya no
tenemos un grupo car box y lo que
tenemos aquí un enlace simple en lugar
de un enlace doble a este oxígeno que
sigue teniendo este par de electrones
tiene un enlace con un hidrógeno pero
ahora se quedó con los dos electrones de
este enlace doble entonces tiene un
segundo par de electrones libres por
otro lado aquí tenemos todavía este
enlace con el grupo
h este grupo h y esta molécula de etanol
en red
y ahora ya no es una molécula de etanol
se agregó a esta molécula con este par
de electrones se formó un enlace entre
el oxígeno y el carbono del grupo car
box y lo entonces este oxígeno ahora no
tiene dos pares de electrones libres
únicamente tiene un par de electrones
libres sigue teniendo el enlace con un
hidrógeno y con esta cadena de dos
carbonos ahora como acaba de perder un
electrón dándoselo a este carbono
entonces este oxígeno tiene una carga
positiva y bueno otra cosa importante es
que todos estos estados en realidad
están en equilibrio podríamos pasar
igual de fácilmente de este estado a
este estado como de este estado a este
estado entonces
realmente debería dibujar estas flechas
de esta forma indicando que todos estos
estados están en equilibrio y entonces
pues bueno seguimos en una solución
llena de protones en cualquier segundo
nos pueden agregar un protón a
cualquiera de estos hidrógenos o también
en cualquier segundo nos pueden quitar
uno de estos protones ok puede ser que
llegue un millón del ácido sulfúrico y
se robe este protón o también puede ser
que otra molécula de etanol llegue y se
robe este propón y bueno de hecho hasta
podría hacer que este protón terminará
en este oxígeno pero bueno mejor vamos a
dibujar por aquí otro etanol
con sus dos pares de electrones y llega
a este etanol y se roba el protón de
este hidrógeno y entonces el electrón
del hidrógeno va a dar al oxígeno y
entonces el oxígeno vuelve a ser un
oxígeno con carga neutra pero bueno
dibujemos otra vez esto que es una
molécula derivada del ácido tánico
tenemos por aquí 2 3 4 5 6 7 con un
oxígeno que está enlazado con un
hidrógeno y luego otro oxígeno que está
enlazado con otro hidrógeno y finalmente
este otro oxígeno que ya no tiene esta
molécula de hidrógeno este protón ya se
fue con este otro etanol a flotar en la
solución pero pero este oxígeno tiene
otros dos carbonos y tiene sus dos pares
de electrones ahora en el siguiente paso
cualquiera de estos oxígenos podría
obtener un protón más o sea ese es justo
el punto de tener como catalizador
ácido sulfúrico que hay un montón de
protones flotando por ahí digamos que es
este
tenemos aquí sus dos pares de electrones
este oxígeno se va a terminar quedando
con algún protón que puede provenir ya
sea del ácido sulfúrico o de lyon del
etanol que tenía un hidrógeno más o de
cualquiera de estas otras moléculas de
en medio como tenemos como catalizador
al ácido sulfúrico hay un montón de
protones que se pueden encontrar con
este oxígeno entonces tenemos por aquí
un protón y este oxígeno le va a regalar
uno de sus electrones y se va a formar
un enlace entre estos dos y entonces lo
que tenemos es dos tres cuatro cinco
seis siete y luego un oxígeno que tiene
un hidrógeno y este carbono que era el
carbono del grupo car box y lo está
enlazado también con este otro oxígeno
de aquí
oxígeno con sus dos pares de electrones
y sus otros dos carbonos otro oxígeno
pero este oxígeno ahora tiene dos
hidrógenos porque este oxígeno le acaba
de regalar uno de sus electrones
haciendo un enlace con el núcleo del
hidrógeno que es simplemente un protón y
entonces tiene una carga positiva y
bueno nada más le queda un par de
electrones libres mientras que este
oxígeno le quedan dos pares de
electrones libres ahora un solo detalle
es que esto de aquí es un muy buen grupo
saliente ok porque el oxígeno es
bastante electro negativo y con una
carga positiva está abrazando lo más que
puede a todos sus electrones entonces es
un bastante buen grupo saliente pero
bueno seguimos en esta solución llena de
protones y tenemos más moléculas de
etanol flotando por allí
y una molécula de etanol podría llegar y
darle uno de sus electrones al núcleo de
este hidrógeno y entonces este electrón
que antes era del hidrógeno va a dar a
este carbono de aquí y bueno este grupo
ya es un muy buen grupo saliente y si
este carbono recibe un electrón más
entonces este grupo se desliga de la
molécula que damos con este electrón de
aquí y se convierte en una simple
molécula de agua
a ver vamos a ver ahora tenemos 2 3 4 5
6 7 carbonos este carbono está enlazado
con un oxígeno pero ahora el electrón de
este hidrógeno fue a dar al carbono
formando el doble enlace entre sus dos
átomos por aquí este oxígeno con sus dos
hidrógenos se quedaron con este electrón
perdiendo su carga positiva saliéndose
de esta molécula y convirtiéndose en una
simple molécula de agua
y luego este carbono está enlazado con
este oxígeno quien a su vez está
enlazado con estos dos carbonos y listo
esta reacción que acabamos de hacer se
llama esterificación de fisher
i
d
ishares
esta edificación de fisher y sólo un
dato curioso fisher ganó el premio nobel
en 1902 por todo su trabajo en química
orgánica y se llama así porque esta
molécula de aquí es un máster
ok empezamos con ácido tánico en una
solución de etanol con ácido sulfúrico
como un catalizador y la reacción en
realidad empieza por aquí esto lo
podríamos borrar
pero bueno sucede toda esta reacción y
terminemos con esta molécula que es un
máster
ok este es un esther
esther y en esta misma serie de vídeos
vamos a ver mas ésteres pero bueno los
ésteres se parecen mucho a lo que hemos
estado viendo tenemos una cadena de
carbonos y un grupo carbon hilo pero en
lugar de tener un hidrógeno como los
aldehídos o tener un grupo o h como los
ácidos carboxílicos tenemos primero un
oxígeno y después en lugar del hidrógeno
tenemos otra cadena de carbonos ahora
para nombrar a los ésteres te fijas en
esta cadena de carbono que en este caso
son 7 carbonos sin ningún enlace doble
ni ningún otro grupo funcional entonces
es un ept ano
y luego para denotar que tenemos aquí un
esther le ponemos la terminación acto
grave si es un esther entonces tiene la
terminación acto y luego la cadena que
está enlazada con este oxígeno de aquí
la llamamos como si fuera un grupo
alquiló en este caso como tenemos dos
carbonos esto sería un estilo y entonces
ponemos aquí de estilo
estilo y listo este este se llama el
novato de estilo la terminación a todos
nos dice que se trata de un tester o sea
que aquí tenemos un grupo carbón hilo y
aquí un oxígeno esta parte nos dice cuál
es la cadena de carbonos que está
enlazada con el carbono del grupo carbón
hilo y esta otra parte de aquí nos dice
cuál es la cadena que está enlazada con
este oxígeno bueno ojalá que hayas
encontrado muy útil este vídeo lo que
quería hacer era introducirte a los
ésteres y ver un mecanismo de reacción
muy conocido para obtener un esther a
partir de un ácido carboxílicos